we want to help people connect and when
we say that we mean something I think a
little bit different from from operators
and that we're not doing the actual
digital connecting we're trying to help
people connect with other people and
share with each other and share the
moments of their lives in a nap on top
of that but you know when people have
access to that you can stay close to the
people that you love you have the
business tools that you need to be able
to communicate with customers find new
customers when people have the internet
overall you get access to information
health information to stay healthy
education information to increase
opportunities you can find jobs the
economies grow so it's incredibly
important and that's why it's something
that I think we're all focused on and
you know Mark you had a big travel here
you've been to Mexico Colombia China
Indonesia India what have you learned
did I miss anywhere nothing you got
almost everything not own trouble that
much so this has been an interesting
year kind of going around and meeting
with partners and governments and
whenever I go to a new place I try to
also see how connectivity and using
facebook and our apps specifically as
well are impacting people and the thing
that's so striking to me is the lengths
that people will go to in order to get
connectivity so I went to go visit I'm
jakarta and and I guess over the weekend
before I was in the city job Jakarta and
there's this village with that they
called a cyber village because the
citizens basically had all organized
around lobbying their government to get
connectivity to this one place that and
then a bunch of people moved there based
on the fact that they wanted to be
connected and that was the primary thing
that was to turn
where they chose to live you know there
are stories like that everywhere that
you go around around the world
especially in developing countries and
it's just it's really inspiring to see I
mean you kind of when you work on this
to tell yourself these stories about how
you know it helps people stay connected
to the people that they care about and
helps to grow the economy but actually
going and talking to real people who
have fought hard to get connectivity
enabled in their and their home and then
get the benefits of that so if we went
to jacquard and you went to the cyber
connected village in jail did that
school that of another a bunch of great
but but that's sort of innovation around
first pulling that together it surprise
you the effort right so there were
specific things that they needed the
government's to unlock and in order to
make that a possibility all right but
it's interesting it's different things
everywhere that you go so I mean in
India you know it's interesting to see
how Prime Minister Modi used the
Internet as a primary campaigning tool
to connect with people I visited a
village that had just gotten connected
and basically was really interesting to
see how the students there were growing
up with the internet now we're using it
to learn and basically they're all these
adults who came to the village center
where there's connectivity we're asking
all the kids how to do stuff and to look
stuff up because that the kids
understood how to use the internet to
learn and it was something that the
older generation didn't have